i mean it's improving every month and if
he holds this one
just amazing achievement because it is
complicated and the bar is shifting
signs wow could black win if black can
win both of those pawns without losing
any of his pieces oh wow ding has
blended look at him the first blunder in
the final i think so suddenly look at
the black knight the black bishop
they're protecting um the black knight
now attacking the white queen defending
our bishop and no matter where the white
queen goes
one of the white pawns is dropping
i mean somebody's turning around he can
win this he could definitely win this
could win this one and then we will head
straight to tie breaks wow what a game
what a match
thing looks devastating yeah
oh he's yeah look at it
i mean wow will he will he win this
would you reckon you vancouver you can
blackwatch i think black will win this
yeah um i mean especially now that ding
has blundered because they always say
that blunders come in pairs and just
look how upset he is i mean so difficult
to mentally